every day I'm hustling every day I'm
hustling
[Music]
everything
a couple of years ago I was on my way to
work I was sleeping on the train I was
tired you walked in you and see other
people and you woke me up from asleep I
just went to work as soon as I walked in
my headshot was watching on YouTube
video and I was like wait a second I
just saw this guy who is it that went
home watched a couple of videos next
week I was a question what happened then
when you came to the reporting you
literally became my virtual best friend
I walked into the building and there
were so many people pulling up with big
cards and I thought I was never gonna
get this I did not have any money at all
I was like how about me paying me six
months in advance that was about 17
grand theft I didn't have any money
those agents now literally didn't give
me every other day say yes and then
figure the details out like you said
what's your profit I'm working that out
with your whole portfolio you've got now
what are you making a month
[Applause]
ottman huge respect for everything
you've achieved in the last what two
three years thank you very much so why
don't you tell the story of how we got
connected because it's quite a funny
story
um a couple of years ago I was on my way
to work
um and I was sleeping on the train I was
tired and you walked in you and to other
people
and you woke me up from my sleep
basically I looked at you and I was like
who's this arrogant guy and I didn't
think much of it and then just went back
to sleep what was I talking about no
idea you were pointing to buildings I
was like arrogant billionaire maybe
inherited it from his father or
something I was a point to that are we
just buying this and we just bought this
oh probably something like that I'm
talking to my guys you're sleeping
thinking shut up it's really funny yeah
I'm gonna wake you up and then after
Union went back to mine put down my bags
went to work and as soon as I walked in
my head chef was watching you on YouTube
videos
and I was like wait a second I just saw
this guy on on the train who is he then
he introduced me to you
then went home watched a couple of
videos next week I was at your crash
course and then so you were at the time
you're working as a as a chef no I was
literally walking as a KP washing dishes
okay I just thought that I wanted to be
in an uncomfortable position like so
that I can uh get out of it as soon as
possible and make my dreams come true
did you enjoy working as a as a cleaner
not really and that was the whole point
of it I just didn't want to work for
anybody else yeah and you also at
University yeah why did you go to you
know what was the plan I didn't really
have a reason I just wanted to make my
parents proud because of all the
sacrifices that they made to raise me
basically they wanted you to go to UNI
yeah they wanted me to but I knew that I
wasn't gonna become a lawyer eventually
what did you study business law
yesterday law that's an interesting
subject study that it is indeed well
it's not really something that I want to
do so you heard me on the train talking
about how rich I am and all the things
I'm doing you were like what a jerk but
then you saw me on YouTube what switched
what made you think
one minute he's a jerk to one minute I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna go on one of his
training programs I'll I'll have to
apologize that was just my first
impression when I first saw you I was
like oh he's an arrogant guy but once I
met you and start listening to you I'll
I'll have to admit that I was wrong
you're actually a great person and you
give so much back to the community and
helping people well I appreciate that
and first impressions literally are just
you know I mean especially if you're
sleeping and you're like oh this dude's
working me up like don't worry I don't
protect that personally in the slightest
what happened then when you came to the
property investor crash course I just
knew that it was meant to be I literally
you literally became my virtual best
friend I started watching you day and
night for
I wasn't doing anything other than sleep
watching your videos the whole day for
about
two three months and you signed up as
well for the online Advanced Training
yeah I signed up for the DLC next track
and the deal foreign
a couple of deals but then after that I
realized that I wanted to have a couple
of rentals before uh selling deals so I
started watching your rent to rent uh
free content that you have on YouTube
and then I literally tweaked it a little
bit I saw approaching landlords asking
them if they wanted me to manage their
properties in exchange of 10 of their
rental income and once I got about four
properties I had a bit more money and
then from then
from that I started uh getting rent to
rent so talk to me about your first
property and how you found it how you
got it and what what how you structured
it I walked into the viewing and there
were so many people pulling up with big
cards and I thought I would never gonna
I was never gonna get this property I
did not have any money at all but the
deal just sounded great after all my
calculation I was going to make about a
grand and a half per month uh went back
home I put in my offer and the following
day got back to me saying that it was
gone they decided to go with somebody
else and I was like what would you want
from me in order to give me the property
I was like how about me paying you six
months in advance how does that sound
I'm very mad I didn't have any money in
my pocket so that was about 17 grand
that they agreed to offer me to give
them I didn't have any money so I
started reaching out to all my friends
and in less than 12 hours I found the
money addition thing what you actually
did was you did what Richard Branson
said which is say yes and then figure
the details out later right so they sent
you if you've got your references
they've got this and you're just like
yeah got everything and then it's like
okay so then they'll let you get your
foot in the door then you'll figure it
out that's right which is what you did I
never since that those agents now are
literally ringing me every other day
bringing me properties several
properties ever since they gave me four
properties and now I'm in a process to
get the fifth one again with them and
that's the thing as well like I'm part
of what we what part of what we teach is
how to be creative and get around the
referencing and get around the because
everybody can find a problem everybody
could say I've Not got any money I've
not got any references I've not got a
company I've not got this but rather
than saying I haven't got I haven't got
I haven't got I can't do I can't do but
can't do you've got to say how can I do
how can I get and you've got to be a
problem solver and and creative and get
around problems I was just willing to do
whatever it takes to make it basically
so you had no money you had no
references but you managed to secure a
property and what was the structure of
that property was it a rent to rent was
it what was it uh rent to HMR okay so
you're renting this and how much are you
renting it for the first property I
rented it out for three thousand pounds
and um
after all expenses
was netting 1500 per month so that one
property was making you a grand and a
half yeah that's incredible bro that's
right the second one
is not in two grand per month profit
that's right and where are these around
London mainly North London so how are
you managing to get so much rent why are
the landlords not just renting it as a
HMO themselves because they don't really
want to be dealing with tenants
I recognize that it's really hard to be
there dealing with tenants every time
especially when the troublemakers and
they would rather get a middleman to
deal with it and just receive that
passive income and just have the Peace
of Mind basically so how much are you
paying on average how much are you
paying the landlords it depends a three
grand in average per property three
grand this is an interesting thing as
well like when you started you had no
money but a lot of people when they've
not got money
they think they want to rent to rent
they think I want rent to rent to get to
build up my cash flow but even if I put
a rent to rent in front of them said
there you go they wouldn't sign it
because they're chicken out because we
have a rent to rent actually if you're
having to commit to pay 3 000 pounds a
month
and then you've got to pay the bills and
then you've got to pay it's a lot of
money to commit to paying isn't it
that's true yeah but you
you can't just have the reward without
having any risks involved life is a risk
itself so you have to be willing to put
yourself out there and make some
sacrifices in order to get the rewards
yeah it's so true but the interesting
thing is
rich people and business owners have
high expenses people people that are
struggling financially think I need to
work harder and I need to just spend
less money and stop drinking Starbucks
and cancel Netflix subscription but
actually that will lead to Poverty
that's a that's a poverty trap what you
need to do is you need to actually have
more outgoings but the right kind of
outgoings you know so taking on a rent
to rent actually increases your monthly
expenses that's true it does but then
your profit is what matters what's your
profit roughly now with your whole
portfolio that you've got now what are
you making a month with my last property
now a bit over eight grand eight
thousand a month eight thousand three
hundred something like that and how has
that changed your life I mean are you
still working as a cleaner uh no no I'm
financially free I'll I will admit that
I still have the debts because I didn't
really have money so I asked in friends
and family to loan me money to in order
to get the properties sure but once I'll
pay everything back then I'll
practically be financially free so
you've borrowed money from friends and
family to to initially pay for some of
your your business all of them how did
you pay for your um training because I
only spent a couple of thousand just on
training borrowing money so you
basically borrowed loads of money to get
to the point where you're at now but now
you're making eight thousand three
hundred pounds a month profit
um you're paying slowly back your debts
talk to me a little bit about good debt
and bad debt because you've got into a
lot of debt which a lot of people would
think oh my gosh that's really bad but
there is a difference between good debt
and bad debt without a doubt in my
opinion
um had good debt uh the reason why I
said that is because every single
property was literally infinite return
on investment I didn't really put
anything from my own pocket so
everything that the properties are
making is literally
profits yeah so what are you doing are
you paying your debts back in terms of
are you giving them interest or are you
giving them a profit share of the
properties no no no just interest okay
and how much roughly are you paying
interest 20 oh wow I was just generous
because I was like is infinite return on
investment I'm not really putting
anything down they're helping me let me
help them as well at the end of the day
is a win-win situation so it's a little
bit like a profit share almost because
even though you're giving them a fixed a
fixed percentage of 20 which is really
high who are these people your friend's
family yes friends friends about 20 of
the money that they borrowed me not the
of the property so once for every
thousand pounds that they gave me I give
them 200 pounds back so once that's paid
back everything that the properties I
make is mine how do you manage to get
people to lend you money for your rent
to rent properties and also for your
training
um like what what do you have in place
and what do you have to say to get them
to agree to give you thousands of pounds
in my opinion it's just by being honest
transparent there have been friends for
a long time and I happen to be
surrounded by good people so if I ask
anybody that is around me they'll just
give me money without hesitation because
they know that if they do
they will get their money back basically
so you've got a bit of a track record
now that you pay people back this how
much outstanding how much outstanding
debt you have I really don't want to
focus on that I have no idea it's a lot
of money but I really don't want to
think about it every time I have some
money I just pay them back I have
everything written down because that
will
make me think negative so I just right
so yeah but you're right though in a way
rather than focusing on the debt what
you focus on expands yeah every time an
agent calls me with a new property I'll
be like yeah I'm taking it even though I
don't have the money and then I'll call
my friends Whoever has some money
they've sent them to me right away get
the property do the works went out what
would happen if
the rent to rent properties didn't work
out
I really think that's not
an option yeah there is rent demand is
always there right so it's almost
impossible for it to not work out but do
you have like break losses on your
Enterprise yeah so you have a break
Clause meaning that if whatever reason
it's not working to plan of course you
can give the keys back because within
the first six months if I rent out the
property and for some reason I don't
like it I'll be able to walk away from
it how do you spot a good deal versus a
bad deal or how do you tell if a deal is
going to work how do you know if it's
going to work I just walk into the
property view the rooms and I kind of
know how much rooms rent out for and
depending on how much the landlord wants
I'll be able to kind of tell I mean by
doing this after a while it becomes
automatic so just so you know that
you've got to know the area you've got
to know the demands so you'll be able to
walk in and go I could rent that room
out for a grand I could rent that room
out for 7.50 that's right I know how
long it would take I know my market I
know the type of people that we live in
here on the landlord wants X if I
negotiate it down a little bit then then
I'm paying the bills and this and you're
going to just work out your profit
margins and then boom and interesting as
well the do you own any Properties or do
you control all of them I'll control
them all so you're making eight grand a
month but you don't actually own you own
your business but you don't own any
properties actually uh one is in the
process of uh to be a lease option
agreement the last one talk to me about
what lease option agreement is because
that's like incredible so it's a great
house has the potential to be extended
in front on the side and the back good
uh on the Loft the garage can be
converted into a two-bedroom house it's
just for infinite potential yeah and the
house is outdated because the parents
died and the sons are just trying to get
rid of it uh the property is up for
515 and if it's done up as it is it will
be worth 850. so basically offer them
five three five in five years and in the
meantime I'll be paying them 2 200
pounds for the next five years so you
basically it's like a bit of a delayed
sale right so you've agreed to buy it
for five three five you're gonna then
get a restriction on the property they
have to sell it to you and only you yeah
you're then going to fix it up a bit
push the value up you're going to
probably borrow that money from friends
and family or maybe you or maybe me but
the thing is if you if it's not like
you're continuing to borrow money to go
on holiday to buy a sofa to buy that
would be leading you into a downward
spiral you're borrowing money but you're
using that money to invest it in stuff
that's giving you cash flow and going up
in value that's why it's good there so
by the time you come to pay for it
it's going to have gone up massively in
value you can refinance it if you're
paying them 2 200 300 2200 are you
making profit on that a month as well
yes it's a seven bedroom it's a five
bedroom house that is plus uh one
reception room so you're gonna rent it
out room by room yeah make a nice profit
from it I mean if everything goes to
plan and uh we send the uh lease option
and we go ahead with it then yes that's
a great way of building your capital
appreciation without actually having to
put down deposits on buying a house what
is it that you would say to your
two-year younger self you know when you
were like let's say on that train that
one day on your way to work to clean the
dishes or or you're at your first ever
property investors crash course knowing
what you know now you've been through it
what would you advise yourself from two
years ago what are the biggest things
that you've learned to not judge a book
by its cover I shouldn't have really
uh made us an assumption about you and I
mean and watch your videos because
they're really helpful and will help
whoever is watching to set up their
business and become successful as well
what are your plans for the future what
you're hoping to do over the next sort
of few years uh sign up for the Academy
because I want to get full time into
development so you want to start doing
bigger deals doing developments and you
know I think you know the way that you
are you you inspire a lot of people
around you I know your brother as well
yeah he's also got into property more
recently how's he getting on it's great
as soon as uh I started getting a couple
of properties he was like oh I want to
do it as well I didn't really teach him
anything I was like okay go on YouTube
search someone let's watch all these
videos and that's it that's all you need
to get your property he asked me again
he asked me again and I kept saying the
same thing go on YouTube watch his
videos that's all you need and then he
started watching the videos and all of a
sudden he called me literally after he
took the computer started looking for a
property within two days came to me and
was like I found the property we went
and viewed it and I he secured it and
literally a month later that property
became successful and he's making 1400
something per month just out of one
property that's like a full-time this is
revolutionary stuff isn't it absolutely
yes it's it's unbelievable the fact that
you were making how much were you making
when you were cleaning dishes 700 800
pounds a month so you're making 700 800
pounds a month you ten times that yes 10
times what you're making oh this is just
the beginning and this is just the
beginning another question I've got for
you is you talk about how great YouTube
is which I agree of course my YouTube
channel is ridiculously valuable because
I give so much on YouTube I give so much
away for free
um but then you also talk about how you
know you invested a couple thousand you
got to get training you're now about to
enroll on to the academy which is you
know 12 000 pounds it's not small amount
of money
what's the and it's a genuine question
what's the purpose of why would you pay
for education and mentorship when you
can get it online for free well if
people think that education is expensive
the better wait until they get handed
the bill for
being broke or and having to work a
regular job for the rest of your life
yeah that's in my opinion it's kind of
it does not really make sense you have
to invest in yourself in order to
get the knowledge that you need to
succeed in whatever field you want to
get into but why would you not just do
it for free on YouTube you have to pay
for somebody's experience to avoid the
mistakes that they did yeah that makes
sense I mean I mean I guess
it's almost like if you want to learn to
drive a car I guess the way I would put
it because I get asked this question a
lot that's why I was interested in your
opinion if you want to learn to drive a
car yes you can learn on YouTube and you
can read the theory book and you need to
do that and that's good but the real way
to to learn something is to just do it
and to do driving you need to do it with
the driving instructor next to you
otherwise you're going to crash like you
said if you think education is expensive
try the bill for mistakes so I guess the
way that I certainly justify because I
go on a lot of courses and training
programs I've had a lot of mentors is I
just think I want someone with me in the
room that can help me along they can
fast track me it's quicker you know and
I think I think no one blinks an eye
when people go to university and spend
30 40 50 Grand to get a degree like you
did I'm sure you've now got a lot of uni
debt I cannot regret it I'm a hundred
thousand in debt and uh for a piece of
paper that I'm not really going to use
is that how much it cost you to get your
law degree Yeah a hundred thousand is
ninety six thousand pounds in depth 96
Grand but no one will blink at that
and you'll go yeah well my mom's happy
was it worth it just to see my parents
smile I guess but no I would rather send
them some money from my properties every
month that would make them smile even
more if you gave him 96 Grand as a
deposit to buy their dream home maybe
that would make them smile more I mean
96 Grand at Uni and you knew that you
weren't gonna
go on to do that yeah I just didn't see
myself working a normal job and be
living an average life so you finished
you know when did you qualify about a
year ago that's a lot of debt bro but
here's the thing guaranteed everybody
watching this video
if that got anything negative to say
they'll be like oh you're in debt
because of your rent to rent you
borrowed money but what about the 96
Grand unit no one will care about that
even though the uni debt is more worse
debt in my opinion it is indeed because
now I I don't like when I have that so I
kind of feel like I can't breathe
especially if it's bad if it's good that
you'll be like okay it's paying itself
then true it's not your debt when I ask
you how much debt you're in you're like
I don't even know all care I don't want
to focus on it because it's just being
paid back and the only reason I've got
profits from this is because I took that
in the first place so the debt will pay
itself back as a matter of fact I kept
going holidays every time you reached
out for an interview it was somewhere in
the world yeah I know bro it took me a
while to get this because you do travel
but you're in Dubai you're here you're
there
you're born in Morocco that's right yeah
and then grew up in Italy yeah now
London where do you think are the best
parts of London for investment I just
focused on North London so I'm not sure
when it comes to buy I would rather
focus on up north it's where you can buy
low and rent high but other than that
[Music]
I would say East London as well when it
comes to buying maybe I think if you're
buying to develop London's good I mean
I've got a lot of developments around
buckinghamshire which are very
profitable land and all kinds of stuff
but if you're right if you're buying
just to buy and rent out then you're not
going to get the returns in London
that's right yeah then you would in the
Midlands or in the north of the country
um what would you say has been the
hardest point you say you've not got any
regrets fair enough but what's the
what's been the most challenging point
of this entire journey I don't really
think I have any challenging point I'll
be honest because I don't know I just
once I am obsessed with something I'll
just stick to it until you become
successful so I really don't see any
setbacks how do you get the time to
continually be traveling the world when
you've got so much responsibility here
in London with all of these properties
there isn't much to be done to be honest
once all the properties are rented out
and you make sure you've done your job
properly
don't there isn't really much to to do
to be honest so you've systemized it
pretty decently yes absolutely so how
does it feel to be making 8 300 pounds a
month profit and not have to go to work
and travel the world like that's crazy
bro it is great it's a great feeling
you don't have to answer to nobody you
can do whatever you want whenever you
like why do you think more people don't
do property investment why don't why
isn't everybody doing this no no and
they're wrong for not doing it I guess
I mean this is the best investment I
could have ever made and worse than that
is a lot of people not only do they not
do it
but they find reasons and pick holes and
say things like
oh but it can't work the Market's Gonna
Change we're entering a recession this
is gonna and it's like man you you know
not only are you not winning but you're
hating on those that are winning and so
how do you deal with negativity
um I found out that most people are very
negative I try to not be negative at all
every time somebody comes with an idea
I'll be like okay let's make it happen
I'll try to work it out find a way to
make it happen and then if I really
think it's not going to work for me I'll
be just moving on but I'll still give it
a go and try to have you had anybody in
your circles from uni or work that have
been negative or tried to hold you back
while you've been doing this absolutely
everyone everyone really yes everyone
around me is very negative to be honest
everyone told me stop playing games go
get a real job
uh stop dreaming
and I guess they were wrong what's your
message to those people now try to be
less negative and try to
go after your dreams I guess that's
another thing as well about
networking and training and the academy
and things like that is it's about being
around other winners that's right
because your environment you know people
Network environment is in my opinion
hugely important this is something a bit
crazy but because I was surrounded by so
much negativity every time I went to
work I was working in a very uh Posh
area so um every time I saw somebody
with a nice car I was literally walked
and walking to them and asking them if
you don't mind me asking what do you do
for a living just for a bit of
positivity around me basically yeah what
is the best thing about having money the
freedom to do whatever you want
basically and not having to answer
anybody and give back when it's possible
I remember as well do you remember the
freedom foreign intensity of the online
yeah and we were speaking and that was I
think that was just the beginning of
your journey yes that was
what happened
it's almost changed ever since I mean
he's just been surrounded by so many
successful people and like-minded people
that gets you in a position to do
and put so much work into your journey
and make it happen basically what's your
message to anybody watching this you
know what someone leads well I
appreciate you coming down to my house
it's been a great interview and
hopefully people will be inspired and
enlightened and massive congrats on your
success thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]